bien mes chers collègues nous sommes
réunis ce matin pour aborder le sujet
des difficultés des entreprises face à
la pénuie de foncier économique je vous
souhaite à toutes et à tous la bienvenue
cette pénurie du foncier économique est
au cœur de l'une de nos missions flash
de cette fin d'année
2023 nous avons ainsi désigné la semaine
dernière deux rapporteurs sur cette
mission entre guillemets flash Michel
mass ici présent et Christian Klinger
qui vous prie d'excuser étant retenu par
la séance inaugural du ched le cycle des
hautes études pour le développement
économique nous nous inquiétons des
chiffres frappants qui ressortent des
récentes études 2 ti3 des
intercommunalités ont déjà été
contraints de refuser des projets
d'implantation d'entreprise faute de
foncier disponible en île et villenes
par exemple 190 entreprises ont déjà dû
abandonner des projets de développement
93 % des zones d'activité seront
saturées en 2030 et un/4 le sont déjà or
22000 hectares seraient nécessair d'ici
2030 uniquement pour remplir les besoins
de la
réindustrialisation on doit donc
s'attendre à un impact économique majeur
du manque de foncier pourtant si l'on
souhaite réindustrialiser le pays faire
croître nos PME et ETI accélérer la
décarbonation de l'économie de nouvelles
implantations industrielles seront
incontournables mais c'est aussi un
sujet pour les activités commerciales
qui avaient déjà été reléué vers des
zones d'activité périphérique et qui
sont confrondé à la dégradation du bâti
dans les centrebourgs dans ces
conditions ou
s'installer l'enjeu du fonciux
économique fait par ailleurs directement
écho à un objectif dont la délégation a
fait l'une de ses priorités la
simplification des normes applicables
aux entreprises nous entendons sans
cesse que les régimes d'autorisation les
procédures sont trop complexes et
surtout trop longs pour que les
entreprises s'installent c'est dissuasif
et cela réduit réellement l'attractivité
de la France comme tare de
production lorsque des entreprises
jettent l'éponges face à la
multiplication des délais des recours
contentieux vis-à-vis de leur
implantation c'est de l' de l'emploi et
du revenu en moins pour les territoires
d'accueil pour lancer nos travaux
l'audition plainère qui nous réunit vise
à faire un premier état des lieux de la
pénurie de foncier économique nous avons
souhaité entendre l'ensemble des voix
des élus aux entreprises en passant par
l'administration les experts nous
accueillons donc pour représenter
l'intercommunalité de France Monsieur
Michel le prêtre président de
l'établissement public territorial grand
Orli Seine Bièvre et administrateur
d'intercommunalité de France Monsieur
Thomas
gousen sous-directeur de la politique
industrielle à la Direction Générale des
Entreprises la DGE du ministère de
l'Économie des Finances de la
souveraineté industrielle et
numérique Monsieur jean- Thomas
Schmid directeur général d'epner
entreprise de transport et de logistique
originaire d'Alsace et enfin en sa
qualité de contributeur à la mission
pilotée par le préfet Michel blzo Mchel
blzau pardon qui a rendu un rapport au
gouvernement sur la mobilisation du
foncier industriel Monsieur François
noisette ancien inspecteur général de
l'environnement et du développement
durable monsieur je vous remercie tous
de votre présence aujourd'hui au Sénat
je vais tout d'abord vous cédez chacun
la parole pour un propos liminire
essayez de pas trop dépasser 8 minutes
pour à laisser le maximum de temps aux
échanges qui devront se terminer
impérativement à 10h15 plus tard nous
souhaitons recueillir votre témoignag
concernant à la fois les constats les
évolutions récentes et vos éventuelles
propositions ensuite mes collègues vous
poseront leurs questions à commencé par
le rapporteur de la mission Michel
Masset et en l'absence de Christian
Klinger je poserai une ou deux questions
à nos invités je rappelle que cette
table ronde est retransmise en direct et
sera disponible en vidéo à la demande
sur le site internet du
Sénat j'incite mes collègues qui
souhaitent poser des questions à
s'inscrire assez rapidement auprès de
Stéphanie messieurs à vous la parole
donc en commençant par le président
Schmidt puis le président le prêtre
monsieur gousen et enfin Monsieur
noisette si vous le voulez bien
merci c'est sûr ok TR bien vous
m'entendez
bien bien mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le Président merci
beaucoup de de nous accueillir
aujourd'hui
pour c'est bon euh pour pour écouter
notre témoignage alors j'agis en tant
que enfin aujourd'hui je je témoigne en
tant qu'effectivement président de de
notre entreprise éepner mais l'idée
étant de vous donner un aperçu le plus
global comp enfin le plus global
possible de la situation de notre
secteur en propos liminire je
souhaiterais
simplement déjà couper cours à
l'opposition qui se fait assez
naturellement entre la
réindustrialisation de la France et la
partie
logistique je pense que c'est une
opposition qui est assez malsine et qui
ne peut que conduire qu'à faire des
erreurs d'analyse d'abord la la
réindustrialisation ne peut pas s'opérer
sans une chaîne logistique performante
euh qui permet à la fois
d'approvisionner en matières premières
évidemment et puis de distribuer
l'ensemble des produits finis en France
comme à
l'export et cette réindustrialisation a
besoin d'un réseau logistique qui est
absolument
indispensable autant il peut y avoir une
logistique sans industrie autant une
logistique autant une industrie sans
logistique n'est absolument pas
envisageable ça c'est un point qui me
paraît essentiel en général le propos de
la logistique seule est assez inaudible
mais si on rejoint les deux enjeux je
pense que on met le doigt sur l'enjeu
essentiel qui est qui est aujourd'hui le
nôre alors je voudrais rentrer un peu
plus dans le détail sur les difficultés
que notre secteur rencontre dans sa dans
son ensemble alors si vous voulez je
pourrais illustrer par un certain nombre
de d'exemple qui concerne notre groupe
euh le premier la première difficulté
qu'on rencontre c'est évidemment et très
naturellement la rareté du foncier alors
je vais donner quelques chiffres qui
sont ceux qui sont transmis par apilog
et mon syndicat professionnel c'estàdire
rtlf d'abord le taux d'occupation actuel
du parc àoisine les 98 % c'estàdire
qu'on est vraiment quasiment à
saturation ce qui engendre des
conséquences et des effets de bord assez
assez néfastes he d'abord un éloignement
des barills centres idéaux hein
théoriques et donc à la fois
l'augmentation des kilomètres donc des
coûts mais aussi de des émissions de CO2
une difficulté pour les industriels qui
qui voudrait produire à trouver des
entrepôts pour stocker leurs
marchandises euh une augmentation des
loyer et un coût des prestations
logistiques en général qui augmente des
taux de vacances très faibles euh alors
ils sont en dessous de 5 % en dehors de
trois régions qui sont le Nord là il y a
peut-être un petit peu plus de c'est un
petit peu plus vert euh de la Normandie
et du centre Val-de
Loire qui sont effectivement dont les
taux de vacances sont sont sont sont un
petit peu plus élevés que 5 % mais pour
le reste on est souvent en dessous de 2
% de taux de vacan alors qu'on considère
qu'en moyenne il il faut un taux de
vacances de 8 % pour que le marché soit
fluide en matière de foncier logistique
et je voudrais rappeler un point
important puisque le foncier logistique
c'est évidemment des choses très
visibles euh donc quand on voit les
choses ça marque et ça ça ça ça
impressionne mais le foncier logistique
aujourd'hui ne pèse qu'1 % dans
l'artificialisation dans le foncier
artificialisé en France là où les
logements pèse 40 %. évidemment on parle
pas des mêmes choses mais c'est donneré
des ordres de grandeur euh je voudrais
voudrais aussi soulligner dans les dans
cette partie là la les inquiétudes
engendrées par la mise en œuvre du
zan il faut faut noter que les les les
bâtiments logistiques sont en moyenne
très grands déjà il y en a des
d'excessivement grands mais il y en a
des déjà des grands puisque la moyenne
c'est 18600 m² pour un anthopô
logistique les 10 % des plus les plus
grands font qui c'est qui dépasse 35000
m² représente 40 % de cette surface
totale qui est complétée par la
logistique et donc ça nous fait craindre
une surreprésentation dans l'aménagement
foncier de ces bâtiments logistiques qui
seraient évidemment pointé du doigt mise
à l'index parce qu'effectivement la
taille l'empreinte qu'elles auraient sur
le foncier disponible serait très
important vis-à-vis d'autres projet mais
encore une fois je rappelle le le
caractère très
important une réponse inadaptée avec les
friches industriel je m'explique les
friches industrielles effectivement on
peut considérer que c'est une très bonne
idée dans le dans dans dans la manière
de de réindustrialiser puisque c'est du
foncier qui est disponible enfin il y a
un certain nombre de contraintes d'abord
des coûts inhérents à l'installation des
pollutions et cetera qui sont quand même
réelles on a par ailleurs souvent des
zones des friches industrielles qui sont
d'ors et déjà inexploitable parce
qu'entouré de zones résidentielles qui
rend l'acceptabilité de ces projetsl
parfaitement parfaitement inaudible
quand vous venez avec vos camions qui
abîment la voirie qui font du bruit et
cetera déjà que l'industrie est pas
forcément bien perçu quand c entouré de
résidentiel là pour le coup la
logistique n'a plus aucune chance et le
le les friches industrielles ne peuvent
pas être la panassée pour plusieurs
raisons la première c'est d'une part un
certain éloignement hein des centres
expéditeurs actuels hein puisque nous on
a besoin mais je l'expliquerai d'être
assez proche des centres expéditeurs à
la fois pour assurer l'approvisionnement
des usines et à la fois leur expédition
mais aussi des zones urbaines pour
pouvoir faire la livraison à la fois
économiquement en terme de coût mais
aussi en terme écologique et je
j'illustre ça le foncier disponible si
si s'il y en avait dans les friches
industriel n'est pas forcément aussi
bien bien accueilli que ça puisque sur
1000 projets financés depuis 2020 par le
fond de recyclage des friches seul 164
étaient industriel la majorité en
résidentielle ou équipement public donc
on est effectivement quand même sur une
solution qui est beaucoup beaucoup mise
en avant mais qui semble en réalité
assez peu praticable on arrive donc au
de au deuxième problème qu'on rencontre
c'est-à-dire la localisation
du foncier la localisation du foncier
elle est essentielle évidemment pour
optimiser les les flux ce qui permet à
la fois ce que j'ai expliquer de réduire
le coût de la chaîne logistique
renforcer sa fiabilité en terme de délai
on en a aussi besoin et réduire les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre qui
sont liés au transport de
marchandises et là on a quatre points
d'importance au niveau de la
localisation d'abord il faut que ce soit
près des sites industriels comme je le
disais pour optimiser leur
approvisionnement et l'expédition des
marchandises mais aussi près des c'est
c'est c'est tout le tout l'enjeu près
des zones de distribution pour optimiser
la logistique àale et la logistique
retour je rappelle que la loi GEC va
nous obliger en tant que transporteur à
récupérer la marchandise usagé et cetera
alors ça se fera évidemment dans le
temps avec des ratios et des objectif
bien définis mais ça ça va aussi nous
obliger derrière à retransporter une
nouvelle marchandise pas trop éloigné et
cetera donc à la fois sur la
distribution aval et à la fois sur la
reprise des marchandises usagées on a
besoin d'une logistique qui nous
permette d'être relativement proche des
centresve on doit être près des grands
axes routiers de préférence pour
faciliter l'accès et limiter les
nuisances pour le voisinage aussi et
près d'un bassin d'emploi pour assurer
la main d'œuvre nécessaire parce que
évidemment on est une une industrie qui
est une main d'œuvre peu
qualifiée donc on peut être près des on
peut pas être mais mais quand même
importante et donc on peut pas être trop
éloigner des zones de mise à disposition
des de cette main
d'œuvre la mauvaise lo isation des
entrepôts permet pas aux acteurs de
jouer leur rôle de groupeur je rappelle
que notre rôle à nous c'est d'être les
transports en commun de la marchandise
on est ceux qui vont grouper ensemble
faire un transport et donc faire faire
les économies à la fois de cûts pour nos
industriels mais évidemment d'émission
de CO2 donc vouloir ramener la pollution
qu'on crée localement à son simple état
c'est assez inepte parce que derrière ça
Enjou le fait d'éloigner ces zones
logistiques engendre des des des
externalités négatives bien plus
que la pollution ou les difficultés créé
éventuellement localement je v prendre
l'exemple un exemple qui a concerné
notre groupe à montpier on n pas trouvé
de foncier on a dû imaginer de livrer
depuis Nim vous imaginez d'abord le
surcût opérationnel pour un groupe comme
c'est 350000 € ce qui est quand même
considérable et d'autre part en terme de
production écologique en terme de
production pour nos industriels c'est
absolument
absolument absolument
inefficace 3è point les délais et
l'acceptabilité euh la problématique des
délais administratifs bon je pense que
vous en avez parlé monsieur le Président
en introduction donc je reviendrai pas
dessus c'est très connu ça concerne pas
que la logistique ça concerne pas c'est
ça concerne l'ensemble de de des acteurs
industriels qui s'implantent et
l'acceptabilité des riverins et des
acteurs politiques locaux non plus n'est
pas propre à la logistique mais ce
secteur est site celui qui fait
aujourd'hui le le plus face à ces
difficultés euh on a parlé un peu avec
France industrie et cetera il y a pas
cette même cette même vis-à-vis
vis-à-vis de l'acceptabilité cette même
on a l'impression cette même difficulté
ou l'ampleur de la difficulté je dois
dire qu'en terme de transport je vous
dis on
est traditionnellement assez mal vu on
prend de l'espace foncier on crée un
nombre d'emplois au mètre carré qui est
très faible même si j'y reviendrai c'est
des emplois peu qualifiés donc ça a
quand même de l'importance puis ça
permet de d'avoir des emplois qui
permettent de de de de d'assez vite
monter dans la chaîne de se faire des
self-m Man qui permettent à des jeunes
de d'entreprendre ou d'intraprendre ce
qui est important mais effectivement on
prend de l'espace on crée peu d'emploi
on fait du bruit on passe avec nos
camions on gêne la circulation bref on
est assez mal vu et là on se retrouve
assez vite dans une situation qui
devient de plus en plus complexe pour
nous et je pourrais vous citer une
lthanie d'exemple que ce soit Strasbourg
noisil sec poau donc on est dans des
villes de taille très différentes où
notre voisinage aujourd'hui est
extrêmement agressif à notre rencontre
et nous pousse à déménager ou rechercher
ou ou ou ou à restraindre notre l'accès
et l'exploitation de nos sites euh
plusieurs arguments doivent permettre de
dépasser ces difficultés d'abord les
projets logistiques sont d'une ampleur
et une utilité que j'ai décrite la
problématique de la de la pollution
locale ne devrait pas prévaloir sur
celle deoptimisation des flux c'est ce
que je décrivais tout à l'heure et le
déploiement d'entrepôt a des effets
positifs sur l'emploi dans les
territoires on est quand même le 5e
acteur français euh le le plus important
en nombre d'emplois avec 1,9 million de
salariés euh et plus de 150 métiers
passant par des postes à la fois de
manutentionnaires de conduite de
transport mais aussi des postes de de de
de de de moderne autour de la de
l'informatique de l'intelligence
artificielle jusqu'à la direction et la
stratégie euh voilà le nombre de
important de métiers peut qualifier
permet d'ailleurs un accès à l'emploi
facilité pour des populations
fragilisées vivant dans des zones
prioritaires jant des zones logistiques
euh en moyenne effectivement on crée 75
emplois pour 100000 m² donc ça dit bien
ce que ça dit mais beaucoup plus en
emploi indirect je rappelle qu'un groupe
comme le nôtre c'est 3000 emplois
directs en France mais 12000 emplois
indirects à travers l'ensemble de la
sous-traitance qui est quand même
considérable et ça fait vivre un
écosystème notamment je je le redis dans
des quartiers prioritaires qui
aujourd'hui sont extrêmement importants
je pense sur le plan politique euh alors
quelle solution propose l'élaboration
d'un schéma directeur du foncier
logistique national par par l'État en
lien avec les régions et avec une
approche globale permettant de bien
identifier d'une part les
infrastructures de flux et de transfert
multimodal le rail est pas toujours le
rail le transfert multimodal n'est pas
toujours la panacée mais il faut
absolument creuser cette voie les
grandes zones de consommation avec la
population et les portes de sortie
export pour la destination des flus les
grandes zones de production et portes
d'entrée pour la provenance des flus les
entrepôts existants et les besoins
exprimés mais non satisfaits la deuxième
voie évidemment d'assouplir lean comme
comme comme effectivement un certain
nombre d'acteurs le proposent avec un un
un assouplissement qui nous semble
nécessaire en prenant en compte d'une
part l'ensemble des éléments pour une
implantation réussie l'industrie la
logistique l'infrastructure les
infrastructures les services publics le
logement le transport public distinguer
l'emprise foncière de l'industrie de
l'emprise foncière des secteurs du
commerce et du logement pour une prise
en compte différenciée dans les
objectifs d'usane et enfin
territorialiser l'proche d'Usan en
fonction de la densité des territoires
pour une meilleure efficacité en
conclusion les efforts réalisés c'est
dernières années en matière de
compétitivité sont pourrai être
potentiellement freiné par la rareté
foncière la logistique est indispensable
à la réindustrialisation très
consommatrice de foncier on en est
conscient mais qui doit être valorisé et
la construction doit en être facilité
les implantations logistiques sont
indispensables pour stocker et organiser
le transport des mètres cubes de
produits nécessaires à toute notre
économie on l'a vu pendant le covid la
distribution des produits
pharmaceutiques et
et de santé euh nous a propulsé sur la
première ligne on en était ravi
euh on souhaiterait ne pas que on
souhaiterait que la mémoire ne soit pas
courte et comme les crises successives
récentes l'ont montré disposer de ces
implantations logistiques en France
c'est un enjeu de souveraineté
économique et industrielle voilà merci
infiniment de votre écoute j'espère que
j'ai pas été trop long non parfait merci
Monsieur le Directeur général un un tout
petit point quand vous parlez euh de
certaines facilités pour les entreprises
de logistique qui sont très importantes
j'ai été je crois porteur d'un
amendement sur la loi industrie verte
qui demandait à ce que non seulement
facilite certaines choses pour les
gigafactory nécessaires à la
réindustrialisation mais qu'il faut que
par cascade ça découle également sur les
entreprises autour et notamment les
entreprises de logistique parce que si
on va deux fois plus vite sur les
entreprises de l'industrie verte et que
les les sous-traitants ou les
prestataires ne suivent pas derrière ça
pourra pas le faire bien maintenant on
laisse la parole au président le
prêtre merci merci président merci
mesames et messieurs merci de N de
m'accueillir d'abord au nom
intercommunalité de France pardon euh
dans dans ce débat alors tout de suite
permettez-moi de mettre le mon le doigt
sur une particularité je suis président
du territoire grand ORL Bièvre vous
entendez les mots Orly donc aéroport sur
mon territoire j'ai j'ai l'aéroport
d'Orly j'ai le mine de ringis et j'ai
donc j'ai 50000 entreprises dans le
secteur et et et et je ne veux surtout
pas m'inscrire en faux mais mais mais
vous amener à un constat en ce qui
concerne la la région la région capitale
et et la particularité que peut avoir un
territoire comme le mien parce que il y
a pas pénurie de foncier chez moi il y a
pas pénurie de foncier j'ai 3 millions
de mèes Carr disponibles sur le
territoire 3 millions de mèes carrés qui
ont une histoire industrielle qui ont
une histoire aujourd'hui à réécrire à
réécrire en fonction des enjeux que le
Président de la République a fixé dans
le domaine de la réindustrialisation
nous y sommes prêts nous y travaillons
avec le concept de territoire
d'industrie avec nous sommes retenus
dans territoire d'industrie
2 il y a des raisons objectives de ce
point de vue donc il faut créer les
conditions pour que il y ait des nuances
dans l'approche dans les analyses de de
ce que de ce qui'est le territoire
national je je confirme ce que vous avez
dit en introduction sur sur la vision
nationale qu'on peut avoir moi je
discute avec le maire de saint-nazer en
conseil d'administration ou en congrès
de d'intercommunalité de France il a un
taux de chômage zéro moi j'ai un taux de
chômage à 17 % voire dans des quartiers
à 25 donc on est il y a des
particularités du
paysage économique du paysage industriel
qui que je je je souhaite qu'on soit
entendu et et voilà peut-être rapid
parce que je je sens bien que si je me
laisse aller c'est peut-être la
caractéristique des hommes politiques
mais en tout cas j'ai je risque de
dépasser les 8 minutes mais
rapidement moi je suis confronté à des
obstacles simples d'abord quand je dis 3
millions de mètres carrés disponibles
aujourd'hui c'est c'est c'est une
information que nous sommes en état de
partager parce que nous y travaillons
depuis 9 ans 9 ans au sein du territoire
on a identifié le territoire on a on a
on a on a on a mis le doigt sur la
réalité industrielle historique et sur
ce qui a été dégradé ce qui a été
détruit en mati vous avez moi j'ai fait
une conférence de presse il y a 30 ans
maintenant 20 ans 25 ans pardon où il y
avait devant moi j'avais 10 entreprises
qui annoncé leur fermeture donc à
l'époque c'est ça c'est ça que ça veut
dire donc aujourd'hui on a besoin de
d'identifier le la réalité du foncier et
d'identifier et de définir quels
objectifs on on peut se
pour être dans c'est pas toujours le cas
mais en tout cas pour être dans
l'orientation politique qui est portée
par le Président de la République ou qui
est porté par le le président Bruno le
le ministre Bruno Lemer sur la question
de la
réindustrialisation nous avons besoin je
je pèse le mot je sais que c'est pas
toujours bien vécu de sanctuariser du
terrain de se donner des des outils
politiques des outils d'état des outils
qui nous permettent de créer crer les
conditions de bloquer des des terrains
pour pour leur laisser le temps laisser
il s'agit bien sûr pour faire ça on a
besoin et c'est un des éléments
nécessaires et incontournaablees
aujourd'hui on a besoin de travailler
ensemble institution entreprise acteurs
économique plus financier et l'État on a
besoin d'être dans
une une démarche commune pour pouvoir
pour pouvoir pour pouvoir s'entendre et
pour pouvoir définir
de deè 2uxème remarque sur la question
du foncier quand on a une histoire
industrielle je n'ai pas 1 m Carr où ça
a été industrialisé qui n'est pas 1 m
carré pollué et je le dis sans
provocation et sans qui est personne
personne n'assume personne n'assume un
peu l'État
mais je je vais finir par parler plus
fort je suis désolé pour nous c'est
surtout c'est transmis si vous parlez
pas micro on vous voit mais on vous
entend pas si c'est transmis il faut que
j'arrête de dire des bêtises des
méchancetés alors non plus sé plus
sérieusement donc on a on a besoin de de
de créer les conditions sur pour savoir
qu'est-ce qu'on moi demain il y a il y a
y a objectivement on peut fabriquer des
des des batteries pour des véhicules
électriques on peut fabriquer un certain
nombre de choses il y a le terrain pour
mais pour que ce terrain soit faudra
aussi créer les conditions de la
assignir ce
terrain dans dans mon approche
personnelle je pense qu'on est on doit
se contraindre au même niveau de
dépollution quand on fait du logement
que quand on fait de l'activité
économique c'est toujours des êtres
humains qu'on pose dessus et il faut
toujours il faut toujours assumer donc
il faut créer ces conditions là après il
faut travailler la question moi je vous
ai dit grand or sa Bièvre j'ai j'ai un
aéroport j'ai une mine de ringis j'ai
des voiries j'ai la SNCF et j'ai la
scène comment on travaille tra le fait
de mettre ça en intermodalité pour
justement j'ai écouté attentivement mon
prédécesseur sur la question de de de
pardon de la logistique moi je rêve de
la scène j'ai j'ai j'ai
aujourd'hui un partenaire qui commercial
qui qui fait circuler ses marchandises
sur la scène et je pense qu'il y a
besoin de travailler cette question
comme il y a besoin et c'est je sais que
ça ça ça ça peut parfois énerver de
ramener du train dans le mine de ringis
de manière beaucoup plus conséquente on
bataille pour aujourd'hui pour un train
et le président de du minine de rangis
travaille aujourd'hui à
développer une réponse qualitative mais
mettre des camions sur des trains c'est
pas tout à fait la bonne réponse mais
çaen est une au moins j'ai connu une
mine de ringis il y a longtemps il y
avait 10 trains par jour c'est il y a
bien une logique à reconstruire de de
l'interconnexion pour voilà pourquoi je
dis ça et je ne suis pas provocateur on
a un bilan de santé de la population du
du territoire aujourd'hui j'ai une santé
publique qui est en dégradation du fait
de la pollution et du fait des
pollutions notamment de circulation j'ai
la 4 j'ai la 6 j'ai la 6 bis j'ai la 86
j'ai tout ça dans dans le territoire et
tout ça ça ça use la santé de nos
populations trème élément de je je l'
évoqué déjà un mot couvert c'est la
question de la
gouvernance on ne peut pas se dire que
ça peut rester simple le
simple il faut que ce soit pas faut pas
que ce soit une une faut vraiment donner
du pouvoir à l'intercommunalité comme il
faut donner du pouvoir à la à à
l'entreprise comme il faut donner du
pouvoir moi j'entends j'été invité à la
à la le président de la République a
fait quand a annoncé le territoire
d'industrie 2 j'ai entendu avec plaisir
le fait que l'État était prêt à mettre
des sous ce qui est quand même pas
nouveau quand on parle d'activité
économique ce qui est quand même un peu
économique qu'il était capable
d'investir sur la dépollution qu'il
était capable d'investir sur les friches
mais ça il faut qu' il faut qu'on
travaille ça faut qu'on travaille avec
le politique local le politique général
et qu'on travaille avec les acteurs
économiques pour définir la nature des
projets moi je suis j'ai j'ai des
projets sur le territoire qui ont été
rejetés qui ont été rejetés parce que il
y a la question du calendrier que vous
avez évoqué déjà qui a déjà été évoqué
on a un problème quand il faut je vais
donner le chiffre parce que je veux pas
dire de bêtises je
je si je va dire des bêtises parce que
je l'ai
perdu 17 mois pour un projet pour un
projet industriel en Allemagne c'est 4
c'est un problème
pourtant pour un projet logistique c'est
9 mois en Allemagne c'est 3 donc c'est
c'est y a une réalité à se donner les
moyens politiques donc il faut il faut
avoir l'outil dernière chose que je veux
dire inspirons-nous de ce qui existe par
exemple dans ma région ce qui existe un
outil qui s'appelle les FIF qui peut
préserver du terrain sauf qu'aujourd'hui
on parle logement je dis pas qu'il faut
pas en parler on a une crise
suffisamment aigue dans le secteur mais
on a un problème avec qui parle-ton de
de la création d'un outil d'envergure
sur la question du foncier
du foncier pour l'activité économique
j'insiste il faut sanctuiriser
c'estàdire faut dire ce terrain là oui
il sera et après qui le gère et comment
on le gère et comment on gère les
réglementations pour les faire
fonctionner ensemble voilà j'ai je je ne
veux pas être plus long je je pourrais
l'être mais je je souhaite rester dans
la mesure merci à vous merci merci
président comme quoi la diversité de nos
territoires quand j'entends tous vos
équipements moi je suis sénateur d'un
territoire où il y a pas un kilomère
d'auto de route il y a pas une gare TGV
et pourtant un des territoires les plus
industriels de France contributaire à la
balance du commerce extérieur donc on
fait pas tous avec les mêmes moyens et
un chômage à moins de 5 % on continue
avec Monsieur gousen
ou monsieur noisette
entendez-vous non mais faisons dans
l'ordre bonjour monsieur le Président
monsieurs et madames les les sénateurs
et
sénatrices du coup du coup je je me
présente alors non pas pour redire m
intituler long long long du ministère
mais simple mon rôle en fait
effectivement je suis du coup
fonctionnaire au sein du ministère enfin
de l'économie ministère de l'Industrie
en fait en charge des politiques en fait
industrielles transverse si on veut un
peu par contraste à des politiques
industrielles sectorielles sur le
secteur de l'auto sur le secteur de la
de l'industrie de santé et cetera j'ai
en charge les types de thématiqu sur la
réindustrialisation la décarbonation de
l'économie les entreprises en en
difficulté et cetera et cetera et dont B
du coup un du sujet qui nous a beaucoup
intéressé ces derniers temps c'est
l'industrie verte on a porté le titre en
l'occurrence de la loi industrie verte
en fait là dans dans la sous-direction
du coup les sujets de
foncier de foncier qu'on a notamment
travailler travailler avec François
noisette et le préfet roulant Mchel
blzot dans le cadre de son de son
rapport récent alors je suis d'accord
avec beaucoup de
chos très bien très
bien je suis du coup d'accord avec
beaucoup de choses qui ont été dites que
je vais pas complètement répéter je suis
d'accord aussi à beaucoup de avec
beaucoup de choses que François noisette
va dire donc je vais pas non plus les
les répéter en avance vous proposez du
coup une peut-être là pour une
introduction un angle un peu
complémentaire un peu plus large sur la
politique industriel pour aussi
mentionner en fait d'autres aspects qui
sont importants qui sont en fait un
petit peu en lien justement aussi avec
au fin du fin des implantation
industrielle et donc le foncier le
foncier
industriel pour la présentation je vais
le prendre sur un fil sur 4
F financer faciliter bon F de foncier je
pense je viendra en 3è et un dernier f
sur former en fait les enjeux aussi
enfin humains en fait de compéten
derrière je commence par le premierit je
commence peut-être par un mot sur la
réindustrialisation effectivement enfin
qui est je pense un peu le point
d'origine de ce ce ce débat en fait
qu'on a là discussion qu'on a
aujourd'hui sur le foncier la
réindustrialisation c'est effectivement
un enjeu je pense qui est bien bien
installé aujourd'hui là depuis ces
quelques dernières années dans le débat
public c'est aussi mine de rien
effectivement il fait une réalité en
fait
effective après je pense qu'on peut le
dire notre ministre la suume après un
constat des industrialisation he sur les
quelques décennies en fait qui nous ont
qui ont précédé on a aujourd'hui en fait
une une courbe qui s'inverse en fait
selon les différents indicateurs que ce
soit le nombre de création d'usines et
on a enfin aujourd'hui en fait des
usines qui se créent des usines qui se
créent à nouveau il y en a enfin
quelques centaines quelques centaines
par an on a un solde positif en fait
d'ouverture d'usine par rapport aux
fermeture d'usine sur les indicateurs
aussi de métiers industriel on a des
indicateurs qui sont enfin qui qui qui
repartent à la hausse qui sont
stabilisés en fait depuis quelques
années et qui repartent à la hausse
aujourd'hui donc la réindustrialisation
il y a effectivement enfin une
matérialité un sujet on est plus
entièrement dans un mouvement de
désindustrialisation il y a une
dynamique de
réindustrialisation voilà qui qu'il faut
rendre encore plus ambitieuse permettre
pour la la développer vraiment voilà non
pas juste sur quelques années mais sur
des décennies des décennies à venir ceci
étant dit je reprends du coup sur le sur
le premier f que je voulais évoquer il y
a plusieurs leviers et conditions en
fait pour cette industrialisation le F
de financer enfin les financements
l'équilibre économique la rentabilité de
de
l'industrie sans sans faux semblant
c'est quand même un point qui est enfin
essentiel et principal enfin vu du
secteur vu du secteur industriel le
prier premier point c'est pas avant tout
les enfin les les financements publics
les subventions de l'État le premier
point c'est l'équilibre économique de la
compétitivité effectivement française
c'està-dire sans espérer de de subsides
public est-ce que les conditions enfin
économique enfin d'impôt de salaire de
compétitivité sont rentables en fait
pour un industriel qui va venir
s'implanter en France plutôt qu'ailleurs
parce qu'en fait le sujet de l'industrie
c'est ça c'est que l'industrie ça peut
être ça peut être implanté en France ça
peut être implanté en Allemagne ça peut
être implanté aux États-Unis ça peut
être implanté en Asie une nouvelle usine
qui va s'implanter en quelque sorte elle
a enfin le choix pas toujours des
options infinies mais en tout cas elle a
un choix et les investisseurs
industriels se posent la question et
c'est une condition essentielle
primordiale impérative que en France ce
soit rentable ce soit compétitif par
rapport aux autres zones industriel
mondial en fait d'implter d'implanter
une usine et ça c'est avant tout des
sujets de compétitivité ité il y a des
les des efforts qui ont été fait
notamment sur les impôts de production
récemment dans le quinena précédent
aussi sur l'impôt sur les sociétés sur
la compétitivité aussi des salaires et
cetera et cetera sans faire le un grand
discours mais il y a effectivement cet
aspect là qui est qui est quand même
essentiel une condition principale de la
réindustrialisation le deuxième aspect
du financement c'est aussi effectivement
des intervention publique qui n'arrive
pas sur chacune sur chaque usine mais
enfin il faut une stratégie qui soit pas
du souspoudrage qui soit pas de la la
subvention généralisée on a aussi des
politiques industrielles qui ciblent euh
des secteurs des enjeux sur lesquel il y
en a besoin euh sur des secteurs voilà
enfin important stratégique euh par
exemple sur l'automobile il y a un
mouvement de transformation en fait du
secteur du véhicule thermique ou
véhicule électrique euh il y a un enjeu
accompagné ce mouvement chez les
constructeurs dans la chaîne de
sous-traitance dans les nouveaux besoins
de développement de batterie électrique
en fait qu'il y a derrière et cetera et
cetera euh
ça on a des grands programmes en
fait France 2030 il y a 54 milliards là
sur sur 5 ans qui ont commencé
techniquement à partir de 2022 là qui
sont des grands programmes sectoriels en
fait justement sur l'automobile sur les
batteries sur la santé sur les
métocritiques et cetera et cetera à la
fois des programmes qui viennent en fait
de grandes coopérations européennes
qu'on travaille avec l'Europe les
Allemands les Italiens et cetera et
d'autres programmes qui sont aussi enfin
voilà franco-français
on a des verticales en fait enfin
d'action de pour soutenir en fait des
implantations d'usine des enfin en
France en fait et plutôt plutôt
qu'ailleurs ça c'est quelque chose c'est
quelque chose qui existe et aussi un
autre angle de soutien public qui est
qui est important à travailler c'est par
ailleurs la bonne orientation en fait
des je dirais de l'argent que l'État les
collectivités dépensent de toute façon
en quelque sorte c'est notamment la
commande publique mais c'est aussi par
exemple les aides au ménage jeuraaie sur
l'exemple automobile c'est un exemple
récent par exemple les primes à l'achat
de véhicules électriqu euh c'est enfin
une dépense plutôt voilà lié à la
transition écologique pour acheter des
véhicules électriques il y a un intérêt
à l'orienter le plus possible sur des
véhicules verts en fait qui en comptant
aussi leur empreinte carbone en terme de
construction et ça oriente aussi ces
aides là au ménage en fait vers l'achat
de véhicules plutôt français européens
plus que américains américains ou
asiatique c'est important aussi de voilà
d'avoir une politique industrielle de
financement à la fois sur la
compétitivité sur les aides on va dire
directes en fait aux entreprise mais
aussi sur l'ensemble d'autres types
d'interventions à de ménage pouvoir les
orienter aussi sur les productions sur
les production en fait nationale c'est
un premier point voilà F qui est enfin
qui qui est important commme je pense à
à resituer et qui est un petit peu en
lien avec le foncier je fais une
parenthèse sur notamment le foncier en
fait fr francilien j'avais travaillé
dans les services déconcentrés en fait
en région de France il y a une question
de prix du foncier qui est importante il
y a effectivement comme ça a été dit des
terrains qui sont disponible notamment
en Île-de-France il y en a aussi sur
Melin scénard il y en a aussi sur
d'anciens sites en fait industriels en
Île-de-France il y a un foncier qui
parfois est cher parce qu'il est en
concurrence avec d'autres usages avec
une densité francilienne qui est
importante et ça aussi ça joue le prix
du foncier dans l'équilibre économique
le deuxème F c'est facilité bon en gros
pour recouvrir les questions de
procédure de procédure
administrative on a fait enfin il y a
des constats là qu'on qu'on rejoint on a
proposé du coup une loi industrie verte
que vous connaissez puisque vous l'avez
voté on vous en remercie pour faire
mieux justement sur ces procédures sur
ces procédures administratives sans
renier sur les exigences sur les
objectifs en fait de ces procédures il
procédur environnemental il s'agit pas
de de de dégrader les les exigences
environnementale mais il s'agit de mieux
organiser en fait les procédures pour
justement passer des délais constatés de
17 mois de délais d'autorisation pour
une implantation d'usine à et on va
viser 9 mois en fait d'implantation en
faisant mieux sur l'organisation des
différentes Briges de la de la procédure
et et aussi en renforçant la force de
travail en fait des équipes
instructrices qui sont dans les services
déconcentrés sur les territoires dans
les dans les départements et c'est
important c'est important aussi d'avoir
voir la la bonne le bon staffing comme
on dit en bon français dans la fonction
publique territoriale pour pouvoir faire
tourner effectivement ces procédures
administratives également dans la
loiindustrie verte bah des aménagements
des des enfin des questions de
d'urbanisme de d'aménagement de
planification parce qu'effectivement
quand on parle de réindustrialisation on
en vient à parler d'implantation d'usine
c'est sur des territoires c'est des
procédures qui sont effectivement enfin
locales qui sont voilà qui relèvent de
l'urbanisme de
l'aménagement du lien avec les stradet
des régions c'est des choses qui sont
vraiment à la main en fait enfin des
territoires et des services déconcentrés
qui doivent fonctionner ensemble
effectivement là-dessus à la fois dans
une question planification
d'intellectualisation de où où pouvoir
viser de l'industrie sur sur un
territoire mais aussi en term très
pratique très opérationnel de faire en
sorte que toutes les procédures
environnement urbanisme
aménagement voilà soit soit mise au
carré pour permettre en fait ces
implantations industrielles et que ça se
fasse dans des délais qui sont aussi en
fait un angle de comparaison que des les
grands projets industriels
internationaux notamment c'est aussi un
angle de comparaison que les porte les
investisseurs industriels on entre les
différents pays c'est c'est un angle qui
est pas financier mais qui a un de
compétitivité aussi d'avoir des savoir
dire de savoir convaincre qu'on a des
procédures qui sont qui sont efficaces
et sans renier sur les objectifs qui
sont
derrière le 3è F du foncier
der non justement j'y viens justement
très vite voilà et le 3ème F du foncier
c'est quand même beaucoup de choses
effectivement qui ont qui ont été dites
euh je pense que François nazette
reviendra justement sur sur les ordres
de grandeur et cetera et cetera
simplement deux points effectivement un
peu d'action du la d'actualité du du
gouvernement enfin qu'on qu'on a en ce
moment c'estc du fond des nouvelles
usines enfin et pour un peu faire simple
soit c'est sur un terrain qui est une
friche industrielle à à recycler à
dépolluer soit sur un terrain
artificialisé sur le premier point
effectivement fait évoluer le fond vert
le les friches en fait du fond vert pour
qu'il puisse davantage en fait financer
des dépollutions de sites industriels
pour permettre des des nouveaux usages
industriels et euh et sur le 3 deè sujet
artificialisation il y a un lien
effectivement avec zan avec les
différents aménagements de zan mais que
vous connaissez
que vous connaissez chacun mieux que moi
en fait je pense et le 4e F formation
peut-être plus éloignée en fait du du
directement du sujet foncier et en même
temps s est lié parce que un choix en
fait d'implantation industrielle ça se
fait bon à la fois sur des questions de
compétitivité à la fois sur des
questions enfin de territoire de terrain
mais aussi de terrain qui sont liés à un
bassin d'emploi et c'est un
autre un autre point récurrent en fait
dans les difficultés en fait de la des
des entreprises industrielles qui
s'implantent ou qui qui existent déjà
au-delà du foncier ce sont aussi les les
recrutements les compétences et quand
une nouvelle implantation se crée on
garde à la fois un espace mais aussi un
bassin d'emploi euh pour savoir recruter
en fait à l'ouverture de l'usine enfin
avant l'ouverture de l'usine d'ailleurs
bah les les différentes compétences les
différents hommes et femmes qui seront
utiles à faire tourner l'usine faire
tourner l'usine
infin merci Monsieur gousen monsieur
noisette s'il vous
plaît bonjour je vous remercie bon le
préfet Mchel blzo aurait bien aimé être
là ce matin mais il est au ministère de
l'Intérieur au titre de ses fonctions de
préfet de la Somme et il vous prie de
l'excuser donc une mission sur la
mobilisation du foncier lui avait été
confié sur
l'objectif dans l'objectif de
mobilisation nationale pour le foncier
Industri
avec des questions sur l'offre la de
qualification de la demande et de
faciliter l'accueil des projets bon les
données que tout le monde a vous avez
bien sûr en tête 10 % du territoire
national est artificialisé on consomme
25000 hectar par an et l'industrie la
logistique représente à peu près 5 % du
stock et 5 % de la consommation et
donc le
rapport
coup je vais pas vous résumer tout le
rapport juste cibler quelques quelques
points pour pour le débat alors pour
commencer le besoin sur lequel il y a
pas beaucoup de travaux donc on a fait
un chiffrage sur la base de gagner deux
points de PIB pour l'industrie c'estàd
retourner à la situation de 2008 c'est
pas il y a très longtemps alors
peut-être un peu avant parce
qu'entretemps il y a aussi des emplois
industriels qui sont partis dans le
secteur des services enfin en gros voilà
d'années ça représente 465000 emplois
industriels supplémentaires et ça
nécessite 18500 hectares par an sur 10
ans et donc on les trouve alors la
matière première elle ne manque pas
euh c'est vraiment un constat je crois
qu'il faut approfondir certains chiffres
sont discutables mais il y a du foncier
euh
aujourd'hui l'industrie c'est 225000
hectare si on augmente la densité en
emploi de 1,5 % en 10 ans je pense que
personne ne trouve que c'est impossible
c'est déjà 45000 emplois industriels
supplémentaires
euh sur ces zones industrielles on peut
aussi les études sur les les zones qui
ont été étudiées par certaines
agglomérations rouan saint-nazer je mené
des études au nord de Strasbourg il y a
entre 15 et 30 % du foncier dans ces
zones industrielles qui est pas ou mal
utilisé si on utilise 1,5 % de ce stock
on récupère 3000
haares il y a entre 90000 et 170000
hactares de friche en France le chiffre
90000 c'est sûr parce que c'est les
anciennes usines mais il y a aussi
beaucoup d'autres friches si on en
utilise 10 % pour l'industrie ça fait
9000 hactares toujours en 10 ans et
l'enveloppe du zan pour les 10 ans à
venir c'est enfin pour les la décennie
c'est 120000 hectares si on en utilise 7
% parce que à partir moment
réindustrialise on va consommer un peu
plus que ce qu'on faisait autrefois
c'est 7500 haectares ça suffit pour
boucler
la l'équation pour les 10 ans qui
viennent donc dans notre rapport vous
verrez il y a un graphique qui qui
illustre ça et on a essayé un peu de de
calculer les préciser ces ces
évaluations alors évidemment c'est des
chiffres MACR et ça ne veut pas dire
qu'il y a pas des endroits où il y a des
difficultés euh dans ces chiffres on a
bon euh intégré la logistique inféodé à
l'industrie euh qui d'après les
différents experts consultés
représentent en gros euh 10 % de
suppléments de fonciers par rapport aux
besoins purement purement des
industriels le reste de l'industrie est
une industrie enfin de la logistique est
une logistique de distribution qu'on
parte à partir des ports en importation
ou d'une usine les besoins sont les
mêmes alors dans les problèmes
spécifiques il y a la question des
grands terrains
euh donc les grands terrains c'est en
fait c'est combien plus de 100 hectares
par an c'est en gros un he par un
terrain par an on a beaucoup parlé l'an
dernier des usines de batterie notamment
àunkererque vector
prologium bon ces deux
projets dépasse 100 hectar la première
phase c'est 50 à 70 hectares le terrain
sur lequel ils se sont mis d'accord
après avoir approfondit le les
discussions avec en l'occurrence le port
de derc en gros de 40 % moins grand que
ce qu'ils avaient demandé initialement
et pas pour des projets qui vont être
moins rentables par ailleurs à partir de
2030 sur les très grands terrains si la
transition vers l'électrification de du
parc automobile se fait on devrait avoir
une baisse de la consommation d'essence
et donc une baisse des besoins
raffineries bon donc tous les experts
pensent qu'on fermera une grande
raffinerie avant 2000 1030 où une
raffinerie c'est 450 hectares libéré
d'un seul coup en général sur un site
très bien desservi par le train le
bateau la route est pas tout à fait
entouré par des maisons personne n'a
voulu s'installer à côté des raffinerie
sauf sur la vallée de la
chimie alors il y a beaucoup de sur la
connaissance il y a beaucoup de données
elles sont pas toujours intégré
consolidé parce que elles ont été
produites beaucoup par les collectivités
pour le besoins propres et donc il a
effectivement des démarches et la
mission fait recommande un certain
nombre de de pistes de travail pour
avancer là-dessus
entre l'aide à l'action et puis la
valorisation et la promotion du site
France par rapport à
l'industrie les friches donc on en a
parlé il y en a
beaucoup président le prêtre annoncé le
stock qu'il a à orlye on fait vite le
petit calcul hein rien que sur son
agglomération ça représente 2 % de
l'emploi Industri rel que l'on a besoin
de créer dans les 10 ans qui viennent
euh donc on peut faire c'est un travail
local terrain par terrain il y a pas
d'autres solution avec le propriétaire
avec l'industriel qui est en train de
partir
euh et effectivement il faut de l'argent
on avait chiffré pour 2000 hectares de
friche à remettre en état d'être
industrialisé un besoin de financement
d'un milillard 600 millions dont un/4
apporté par les Collectiv par l'État et
3/4 apporté par les
collectivités sur ce sujet-l sur la
préparation ça prend un petit peu de
temps on a pris du retard et c'est vrai
qu'il a eu un biais de beaucoup utiliser
les friches industrielles pour faire du
logement du commerce et des bureaux les
bureaux ça tousse un peu le commerce ça
tousse un peu et c'est pas forcément les
meilleurs terrains pour faire du
logement j'ai eu la chance de rencontrer
des élus me disant on fait pression sur
moi pour transformer un ancien site
industriel en quartier de logement alors
que je voudrais garder mes Coles bleus
bon je crois que ça c'est des choses qui
sont finies
euh mais c'est une vraie
discussion alors après il y a la
question du temps et des délais on en a
parlé donc oui il faut des sites clé en
main donc les sites France 2030 ont été
ont été annoncés il y a du travail à
faire là-dessus c'est pas que les grands
terrains c'est des terrains avec des
besoins spécifiques on a tous entendu
parler de SMT micro elleectronices à
Grenoble sur il y a des problèmes d'eau
il y a des problèmes pour des
industriels électrointensifs qui ont
besoin d'être à proximité de lignes à
très haute tension on a aussi des
souvent des tas de sujets un peu
particuliers le CVO un besoin
d'accessibilité très particulière en
dessertes ferroviaire dont on n pas
toujours bien identifié tout toutes les
questions et sur les procédures
environnementales il y a des questions
d'organisation dans au cours de la
mission préfère a fait énormément de
visites de terrain on a rencontré des
industriels disant j'ai j'ai un projet
qui a échoué un endroit on m'a annoncé
30 mois de procédure à 100 km de là sur
une autre intercommunalité j'ai fait mon
projet en moins d'un an
donc la législation est la même sur tout
le territoire national c'est donc bien
des problèmes d'organisation de
mobilisation
locale et donc pour alimenter les
échanges
euh quatre points mais je sais qu'il
peut y avoir des discussions he le
foncier existe et on sait faire
euh il faut de l'argent un peu il faut
des administrations mobilisées euh
beaucoup euh et ça suppose aussi des
questions de formation de sensibilité et
cetera euh c'est lié avec le deux points
le deuxième point pour réussir il faut
que l'envie
d'usine soit
partagée nous avons rencontré des élus
disant au titre du de la dans la
préparation du sradet dans les
enveloppes de zan président de inter
communauté disant j'ai eu une dotation
majoré parce que je suis un territoire a
priori euh tout à fait bon pour faire de
l'industrie et de la logistique j'ai une
centaine d'hectares supplémentaires par
rapport à la loocation
moyenne mon conseil syndical ne veut pas
que j'y mette des usines et des
entrepôts bon c'est c'est pas une
accusation contre des élus si les élus
disent ça c'est que la population dit ça
on a un vrai problème d'envie d'usine et
là-dessus donc on a vu des territoires
où il y a des envies d'usine mais les
usines sont là je vais pas reciter
vitré je vais pas citer so Chau mon
Béliard je vais pas citer dans le
rapport on a des exemples saint nazer La
Rochelle il y a des envis d'usine et on
trouve des solutions puis y a des
territoires on trouve pas de solution or
un des grands enjeux de
l'industrialisation y compris par
rapport à l'emploi c'est de redistribuer
l'industrie sur l'ensemble du territoire
national et notamment dans des
territoires dit plus ruraux dit plus
moins dense et cetera ce qui a fait la
richesse des territoires ruraux de la
France de la fin du 19e et du 20e siècle
c'est qu'il y avait des usines à peu
près partout y compris à Ambert y
compris euh dans le Cantal et cetera
c'est ces usines-là aussi qu'il faut
reconstruire et ça aidera à trouver des
réponses logistiques après ce sont les
territoires qui sont à la manœuvre ça a
été dit c'est eux qui mnent qui
maîtrisent l'ensemble des procédures ils
ont besoin d'appui et de financement
mais l'ensemble des procédures
d'aménagement et d'urbanisme sont de la
compétence des collectivités locales
évidemment il faut qu'il le veuilleent
mais la plupart le veulent et puis les
industriels peuvent largement
contribuer alors s'ils ont des
stratégies de développement durable
clair et qu'il les mettent en œuvre on a
aussi des exemples euh des exemples
positifs stellentis aujourd'hui libère
du foncier en compactant ses usines euh
les vent aux collectivités en général
avec des demandes que on les réserve
pour réinstaller les industriels qui
viennent en grappe autour de ces sites
on a aussi et
laindustrie la loi industrie verte a une
disposition là-dessus que vous avez voté
des industriels qui disent moi je veux
pas commencer à dépolluer et donc je
vais garder une petite activité sur mon
site pour qu'on puisse pas dire qu'il
est fermé et que je suis obligé de
remplir mes obligations de dépollution
donc une loi a été passée qui va
permettre à l'État d'obliger à libérer
les terrains mal utilisés
euh mais on a là un enjeu important il y
a énormément de sites industriels qui ne
sont pas utilisés euh complètement avec
une très forte densité d'emploi la
densité moyenne en emploi des sites
industriels et de moins de la moitié de
la densité d'un site industriel
neuf donc si on ramène tout les sites
industriels existants à la moyenne on
peut créer bien plus que 465000
emplois merci Monsieur noisette je vis
juste